hey grant i'm developing a cloud
function
and i'm having issues troubleshooting it
oh uh have you tried debugging your
function locally
oh no i haven't let's pair our program
together
[Music]
so martin what's the issue don't you
write perfect code that works the first
time you run it i
wish let me give you some background i'm
building a cloud function to share all
the cute animal photos you sent me
testing the function is getting fairly
complicated and i keep getting an
error trying to fix it deploy
wait a minute test again it's taking a
lot of time
yeah that does sound time consuming and
risky especially if you're testing in
production
so let's go and i'll check out your code
and your function locally on my machine
sounds great
so here i've checked out your code all
right you're pretty good
coder but that's focus focus grant
um let me go and show you how you can go
and run your function
locally so in this case we got a node
function
to run our function locally i'll first
install
the google cloud functions framework
with npmi
google cloud functions framework all
right i'm a pretty good coder huh
all right but so this is node but what
about
languages other than node my co-worker
for example uses
java oh a great question martin so this
library the functions framework is
available
in all cloud function runtimes so the
process is pretty similar
between python go java ruby php.net
in fact there's a link in the
description of this video down below
with documentation with detailed
instructions for those languages
so next we can go and just use the
functions framework
for that language as a library so you
can run your function locally
let's add a start script so we can
simply run
npm start this will start our localhost
server
serving our function neat
so we can just curl this local host url
and test the function locally
uh-huh oh oh it looks like we're getting
the same error
darn uh now mar martin so this is the
error we want to see it's actually the
same error that we're seeing in
production
but now we can go and test locally
oh i see all right so how do we debug
this locally
well i mean you can go use console.log
statements which i sometimes do
don't don't tell my manager but this can
be a little bit cumbersome
especially with a larger application so
let's go ahead
and set up the node debugger that sounds
good
are you saying that i can use the normal
node debugger
yes so node comes with a debugger out of
the box
we can simply attach this debugger to
our node process
running our function so in vs code
let's use the attach command
oh nice okay all right
so oh i see the status bar change from
blue to orange
yes so that indicates that we've
successfully attached our debugger
now let's go ahead and add a break point
in the beginning of our function
[Music]
to do
[Music]
good good all right and now let's run
our function see if we can catch this
pesky error
all right i'll go and curl our localhost
url
okay i see the editor has paused the
execution on the breakpoint
yep uh in fact if we go and hover over
some variables we can see the current
values
so let's go oh
i see oh look at that oh it looks like
i used rec dot params which should be
rec dot query uh would you fix that
grant
oh yeah sure on silly typo yeah
and yeah yeah looks like there's a
couple few more
errors here i'll go ahead and edit them
and i'm just done so
now that we've edited our code we need
to go ahead and
restart the function for it to take
effect
one second let me go just cancel the
process
restart it and try again
and boom this is great
but grant the function accesses the
firestore database in the cloud
how come that worked when you ran the
function on your local machine oh a
great question martin so the client
library used in the function
picks up the local credentials from
gcloud
in fact i ran a special command
to get these credentials these are
called application default credentials
these default credentials are the exact
same credentials
that you see with cloud functions that's
used in production
so to get this i ran the command gcloud
auth
application default login before i
uh set this so remember
that firestore isn't running on our
local machine
it's the function is using the client
library
and our auth to call the firestore
database
on our cloud project oh
i see uh so grant how about we close the
loop
and deploy the code to google cloud
function sounds great
let me go ahead and run the deploy
script here
see cloud functions deploy all right
looks like it deployed and now let's
curl the function
great curling the function
our url and
it looks like it works uh it looks like
we don't see the error of an undefined
variable anymore
i'll go ahead and click the photo link
and see if it actually works ah
look at that cute puppy martin
yes so furry i'm happy the function
works well it sounds like we definitely
deserve a coffee break
yes we've earned it great
thank you everyone for watching if you
have any questions for me or grant
please add them in the comments below
also please let us know if you have
another serverless topic that you'd like
to see us cover in a video
bye for now
you